this year on September 28th of Taliban
captured the city of Kunduz in northern
Afghanistan they were able to hold on to
the city for two weeks nearly 300 people
lost their lives a shock to German
members of parliament as bundas bear
soldiers had been tasked with bringing
stability to northern Afghanistan for 14
years he invited all cloud it was clear
to everyone that at the end of the
international community's combat mission
at the end of ICF there would be a
Taliban offensive it was like a date or
an invitation that was in a way
predictable when the troops were
withdrawn ziba vonda's bear soldiers
were not only there to train Afghan
security forces but also to accompany
them on missions and take part in
intelligence operations addressing the
Afghan government German Defense
Minister Wasilla fondle and demanded
that engagement not be one-sided is come
in that tap it just can't be that for
years we send our soldiers to
Afghanistan to stabilize the place and
at the same time educated and wealthy
Afghans especially are leaving the
country because they feel there are no
opportunities there was a kind of
perspective is in the chef human Afghan
I've spoken with many Afghan refugees in
recent weeks here in Germany and all of
them are worried that the government
will send them right back to this unsafe
situation and what does interior
minister Thomas de Maiziere say that
German troops would make the country
safer and that's why we can expect the
Afghans to stay in their own country
ladies and gentlemen that's cynical many
here have been disappointed by the
mission in Afghanistan up until now and
the Left Party is against extending it
however the mission has been extended
once again and there's been no mention
of a pullout date